hello everyone thank you so much for
your patience we are here we're up and
running i am so excited
to bring you the first in a series of
interviews uh
with me jason langstor if i run learn
with jason
in partnership with free code camp thank
you so much for letting us take over the
channel
and i am just absolutely thrilled to be
talking to one of my favorite people
today
henri elvetica how are you doing man
honestly
i'm probably more thrilled to be here uh
after
that little bit of hiccup uh for
everyone uh just watching
uh apologies were a little tardy it's
all on me
uh my computer was just acting weird and
you know what i just discovered today
is that the touch id is actually a
button as well
so i was sitting there touching it
touching it
and then i was getting so mad that i was
like wait this just went
down i'm like oh man i didn't know this
oh so
uh regardless thanks for having me dude
uh i think it's a it's an honor
for you to first have reached out to me
and uh
finding out that i'm the first person uh
uh sort of like launching
uh this set of uh interviews so i'm just
beyond delighted i mean i'll go a step
further than that man i i actually will
say that you
are the person who kind of inspired the
whole idea for this
um and we'll talk a little bit more
about why here when we get into it but
so what i what i really want to do is i
just want to say um
you know the the idea behind this whole
series and the reason that we're doing
it
is that getting into tech can be really
daunting right it can be
um it can feel like this endless climb
like you you're just kind of rolling
this rock up the hill and you never know
when it's going to stop
and what i what i'm hoping to do is to
to help encourage people and and um
kind of show that like even if you
haven't been working in tech
you're still actively building skills
that are going to help you
in your career that are going to help
you uh move forward
so where i want to start with that is is
let's maybe start by talking a little
bit about what you're doing now so
do you want to maybe share a little bit
of what what does your career look like
now
certainly um i mean i i've certainly not
uh reached i'd say the the sort of
zenith or apex of my career so far in
tech
but i'm happy to share um i mean i'm
what you would regard as your sort of
prototypical freelancer
uh and uh i probably take that
freelancing
a step further uh in a sense that i may
have
my hands in a bunch of different things
but that's also because i feel that i
also
have a set of skills that sort of
allow me to do so uh essentially so uh i
came from a design firm
you know classic uh you know you know
being on the dev team et cetera et
cetera
uh and then i discovered uh i mean sort
of
the inner layers of the the tech the
tech scene and yeah i saw
you know the conferencing and i saw the
ability to do like some
some tech writing and stuff like that
and i was like oh this is actually kind
of interesting
and um having done freelancing uh quite
often
uh uh man sorry my notifications are
getting crazy
they're making all this noise but uh
having done freelancing in a bunch of
uh in prior careers uh i was very much
used to it
you know uh and uh so it was no
you know uh it wasn't complicated to
really transition to a freelance
environment
so uh after that i just you know even
you know discovering the opportunity to
be an organizer
you know something that i've done
previously as well uh
which is absolutely part of the fold uh
for me now anyhow so
uh yeah i mean like the freelance title
uh tends to be a little boring
you know uh but uh you know when i sit
down
and with people let them know what i do
specifically what i
enjoy doing specifically uh then you
know i start to have this sort of like
multi-faceted uh many hats type of uh
uh title yeah yeah and actually so
that's something that i think is really
interesting about your career in
particular
is that you are a many hats kind of
developer because you work
you do contract and client work um you
organize the jam stack toronto meetup
you're a keynote speaker
you uh you make like swag you've got the
the hip-hop pins which i have i have
some of those sitting around here
actually
oh man i i may have some no where do
they go i
i have but you've got like the ll cool
js and the notorious big data and like
all these amazing these amazing pins um
and so you're
you're kind of across the board and what
i love about it is that
you you have done something that i think
is is really interesting
in your career which is that you haven't
allowed
what you do to box you in to a certain
set of roles or responsibilities and i
think that's really inspiring and that's
that's kind of what i was thinking about
when we started talking about this show
so specifically
um what i'd love to talk about a little
bit is
you don't have a traditional tech
background like you didn't come in
through a computer science college
program
or anything like that so what were you
doing before tech
so uh i mean it's
uh it's absolutely true i did not come
from you know anything cs related
uh i was always curious about you know
cs or
computers in general you know i i
fiddled around as a young man
uh younger men because i am still a
young man
but uh yeah it uh let me see
i started i'd say i mean ultimately i
came from music
you know if i really uh go digging
pretty deep
um you know in college
uh i did i remember doing uh college
radio
you know and i had my own little show
whatever
and um i also had like a part-time job
and i say college college slash
university uh but i also had a part-time
job
at a uh a record chain
and uh yeah i mean i enjoyed it and uh
that led ultimately to working at a
label
and uh as you may or may not remember
because i know
i'm sure you do remember but you know
we've talked about our sort of parallel
paths and whatnot in music but you tend
to
be around that sort of traffic where you
know label execs come in
you know reps uh you know they have you
know
swag or whatever promos and that sort of
brought me into the business side of
music which
i loved uh i may not love as much as i
did back then but uh i absolutely loved
the
the sort of the marketing uh the the
development of careers the development
of acts
uh and stuff like that so that really
enabled me to you know do so many things
um you know being in touch with
you know groups of people all the time
uh
you know people you don't know
necessarily but you know you you get to
know eventually
and you know creating creating a network
of people across sometimes a country
if not a continent you know and these
were you know things that we did in in
in music marketing you know sort of
being able to pick up the phone or send
an email
to a particular you know retailer if not
you know
radio person and and talk about you know
some of your
your sort of priorities at the time so i
definitely did
uh quite a bit of a time in music and at
some point
uh in parallel i started to work in
fashion as well
because an opportunity came up and
neither clashed with each other
on a scheduling level and certainly not
on a content level sure but
back then it was prior to
what i saw happening after which was
uh the sort of like meeting of two minds
the fusing of those two
uh industries you know fashion and music
suddenly
uh working well together hand-in-hand so
and and that was also another
opportunity uh
that i took i took on because that
taught me a lot
you know and i did a bit more of the
sales thing there but there was still
heavy marketing going on and like i said
the music
was starting to fuse in with fashion and
i worked with a
label a clothing label that was very
forward on that level as well
yeah so so kind of talking about like
so you you've worked in in music you've
worked in fashion
uh you you got into a design agency um
one of the things that i've i've noticed
is like just kind of from my own career
uh a lot of the skills that have helped
me progress
have been more on the the kind of social
side and you said something that i
thought was really interesting
which was about building that global
network right and so i remember when i
was in a band
one of the hardest parts of being in a
band wasn't getting up on stage it was
convincing a group of
16 year old kids in a city i'd never
been to to go print out and hang up
flyers for our show
right so what kind of skills do you feel
you developed in in fashion in in music
that have that you use all the time that
you maybe thought would not be
particularly useful at the time oh you
know
great question and you know
i've actually thought about this prior
and uh
i i may have i've mentioned this to you
but you know ultimately i think
i probably will make my way over to like
a devrel position
in tech but i tell people all the time
you know when i
sort of bring up the music bit that i
felt like i was dev railing in music
before i knew what the you know the the
devrel title
in a sense that you know
you first you know you do a bit of a
reconnaissance mission like okay
i'm in this industry who do i need to
know who do i need to talk to what they
did
what do they do uh that is part of my
you know potential potential work
mandate right
and so you know you reach out to them
you know cold emails sometimes but often
enough it's like
you know they know of your company so
they're like oh yeah no doubt you know
blah blah blah
you get in touch and and you start that
way and
you know that could be a national uh
situation but it could easily be
international right right right and and
you know again you know like you said as
a as a
someone who's in a band you know you
know you have like 10 tour dates
and you have to set up these dates with
you know uh
you know some marketing and some radio
appearances and you know
so that means like you know you know
prior to
zooming uh you have to make that phone
calls like hey
x y and z i'm coming to town yeah you
know can i do
a a 15-minute phoner right well
and what you're and what you're talking
about like really is
that's a that's an overlap with project
management that's an overlap
with with like product minded thinking
because you can't just say look one of
the things that i think it gets a lot of
devs in trouble is they think that the
only part of the job is the code
um and and because of that they get a
little bit stuck where they write code
but they're not thinking about how the
code connects to the rest of the product
of to the rest of the company to the
people that are using it
and that kind of lets you you plateau at
a certain point where you can't really
push beyond
and so what you're talking about with
this like you know it's not just
playing music it's not just doing the
show there's all this stuff connected
around it and so you had to develop all
these skills of
thinking big picture and thinking about
how one part would connect to another
part how you could support the work that
you were doing on this
on stage with different things and i
think that's that's just absolutely
fascinating and
such an interesting thing because who
would have thought that being a show
promoter
would help help you become a better
developer right
absolutely and you know it's uh i mean
again we've talked about this before
i've told you like
i i enjoy daydreaming you know
i like to sit down and just sort of you
know take an idea
and start to develop it you know from
start to finish
good ideas poor ones but you know i jot
them all down
and i look for opportunities to you know
take a product whatever it is and
finding out how
i can sort of develop it so for example
you know in music as you remember it's
like okay we'll get the advance okay
what does the music sound like all right
cool
who do i need to reach out to to sort of
you know see this music to
uh get some feedback all right cool i
got some feedback
now i'm potentially going to go to radio
with it boom boom boom here's my
priority here's the product that i'm
working with
you know let me know what your community
says
once you put that out there and then you
take that feedback
and you know it's pretty much the same
with software you know
you know you might deploy something
you're working on it you have an alpha
you have a beta boom boom you put it out
to
uh a few people get some feedback what
went wrong
okay cool take it back and then at some
point you could put out you know
1.0 right yeah it's that whole like 10
years to an overnight success thing
right
absolutely absolutely you know so it
certainly
taught me how to think a lot um i don't
say that i think differently
but i do believe that you know having
come from music
and as you know we have to be thrift
you know we have to make we have to you
know take a dollar
and stretch it like from here to who
knows where like i'm in toronto
i need to stretch this dollar to
vancouver and back
you know yeah absolutely it's uh we we
tend to sort of really be
uh you know potentially a bit more
enterprising than most right
yeah so um and that actually kind of has
me thinking about
maybe some more more practical stuff so
for the the people who are watching a
lot of folks are trying to break in
they're trying to get their first
role um so for the people who are in
that position
you know going back to how you made that
transition when you
when you were coming from from music and
fashion over into tech
what what did you do and like how did
you
how did you make yourself stand out from
the other applicants
how did you actually let's start there
how did you make yourself stand out from
other people as you were as you were
trying to get that first gig
so uh i mean even beyond the gig
um i i'd like to talk about this like
sort of in general
sure uh but um i've always said that
uh you know there are a lot of people
who are
uh equally skilled you know you're
always gonna find that there are some
musicians
who are just like man you know
he's a good guitarist you know his drums
are
you know whatever but at some point
this is like little je ne sais quoi that
makes you stand out
and um you know coming from the arts
uh it could have been a bunch of things
uh
but you know i made sure that you know i
came with a bit of a different flair
uh and i'm not talking about like you
know i got feathers coming out my hat or
whatever but
you know i i i do want to make sure that
you know you're going to remember me no
matter what happens
right um so you know on the work level
you know my first gig in dev uh was
you know i knew people you know and i
knew uh someone who had uh
mentioned that a particular company that
they're working with were looking to
fill in this role
and you know i was lucky enough to uh
make it to the top of the pile of of
applicants
and you know i got through yeah it's all
good
um but you know to me i i've always
mentioned this
and it's you know what's going to make
you interesting you know
and this is something i talk about
sometimes in these these lunch and
learns that i do
you know like you know you go out there
and find your passion
and and sort of work at it right and
i'll be very frank in the
sort of like freelancer role and and
sort of like this whole developer scene
right now um
i think a bunch of things happened um
for what you know this may seem like you
know
such a small thing uh and bizarre thing
to mention
but i was like how you how are you not
gonna forget me
and the first thing was like my my
twitter handle
uh and you know i used to get asked so
much if it was my real name
i was like this is like they're not
forgetting me
right right i mean there's been
discussion about it in the
in the chat today about your about
helvetica is your last name
so that's that's like a developer stage
name right
it's a known plume absolutely you know
it's not my real name but
you know people gravitated towards it so
much that i was like okay when i went to
conferences i just asked them to
to use this as my my uh my name
and you know there are a couple reasons
beyond that i could get into but you
know that was
one and two what i also did was uh
you know when i was sort of you know a
nobody
and i'm just a bit less of a nobody
right now
but i'm still a bit of a nobody
but you know i remember just uh you know
the things i got into
i just started to read about and i used
to start to tweet about it
and if i could i'd i'd sort of tag the
the author and be like hey you know i
really love this
quote boom and you know i'll just put
that out there also to sort of help
myself but
to really just build this this rapport
with the community to let them know like
this is what i'm into
and you know if you go through my
timeline you're going to see a lot more
of this
i remember running into some authors
later who told me they loved it
you know they loved seeing someone
reading about their work
and quoting it to the rest of the world
and
i heard that from authors i heard that
from other developers who just
started to follow me just on that basis
yeah um
and you know that also meant that i was
starting to deep dive in these areas
that i was into as well
and so deep diving sharing my passions
uh
making sure that people would remember
me uh and then
you know things start to happen slowly
thereafter
yeah it well and it seems like i think a
lot of people think that you have to
know everything
um and you know i i think that maybe a
a sign of of growing in your career is
realizing that there's just no way
you're never gonna know everything
um but i think maybe the surprising
thing is that you can
you can really specialize and there's a
lot of work there like for example
you are a um like an image performance
specialist you're you've got one of the
you're like one of the people i see do
the most
uh content about this right and that
that brings you work right so you know i
i never want to
use specialists as a sort of like uh
you know title uh sure certainly
aficionado
uh i enjoy the conversation i enjoy
hearing about it
uh i mean there are some speakers out
there or you know some engineers
uh some researchers in in the the uh
sort of like images and the rendering
scene that
they don't speak a lot but when they do
i enjoy you know i
take time out of my day to make sure
that i'm i'm available
to see their talk you know like people
like uh
cornell zinski he doesn't speak a lot
but i remember a couple years ago when
he was at perth now i was like
you know the minute the videos were
available i was right there watching it
absolutely
so yes you know you tend to i mean you
need to project what people want to see
right
so uh you know if you're going to be a
jerk
project that you're a jerk yeah you got
to get that gordon ramsay energy going
exactly but but you know i
i start to read a lot about uh web
performance in general
you know i start to attend the web
performance meetup which is
uh one of the meetups that i run now uh
and i just started to share some of the
information whatever i had
and i would follow you know a lot of the
uh
the leaders in that field uh the
you know they in turn shared some of
their info and it's just like
you know more for me to ingest and and
sort of like
voraciously sort of uh devour
so um but yeah you know it
i i'm a big believer that uh whatever it
is that you're into
you know maybe you're a css person or
you're getting into css
you know share some of the css knowledge
you have share
you know some of the stuff that you're
reading out there and people then
potentially ask you questions you may or
may not have the answers but
you start that conversation with them
and they'll be like oh yeah that that
person
like you know i love that they share css
or just
a lot of front-end stuff and you know i
can ask them or you know
i know i'll get like some nuggets from
them at some point mm-hmm
so there's actually there's a related
question that i want to dig into scott
uh in the chat is asking so when you're
learning this stuff
how do you show that you know what
you're talking about like especially in
the context of
of going in and applying for jobs
i mean uh you can mention that in in
some of your
uh you know uh in your resume or cover
letter or something like that
or you may have you know a repo where
you're sort of like playing around with
some
some content and and you're showing some
of the results
uh or you may have like a code pen where
you've sort of
laid out these sort of code blocks these
examples of you working on on
on a particular item that you know was
puzzling to you at first but
you're like okay i kind of get it now
but you leave it there out in the open
for the public to see and consume
that's something that i'm very adamant
about which is uh
being public with your work and i'm not
saying that you absolutely have to do it
but if you do you'd be surprised
because this is working on your behalf
while you sleep right right right um i
mean i wish
i wish i pulled up the example um
actually in fact there's so many links i
want to carry
uh for this uh for this uh talk but
we'll make sure they show up in the the
notes on the video so we'll we'll
post some resources on the video for the
replay if for anybody who's watching now
or if you're watching
uh the replay later on uh that'd be
great i mean i could give you an example
where i remember
uh someone had just mentioned that
they're looking for an internship
um you know uh
they're gonna be this is last year
obviously they're going to be free and
whatnot they're ready for the summer
and um oh man what am i
why am i forgetting his name ceo of
shopify
oh yeah i know who you're talking about
i also yes toby yes
he basically went to this person's
github looked through it came back and
offered them to spot
the job on the spot you know in a queen
he was like hey
so and so i just went through github it
looks great i love what you did here
if you're trying to intern with us i got
you right now this is not
hr this is the ceo right so um
i've always said you'd be surprised what
can happen when you're public with your
work
sharing some of that some of that uh
stuff you're working on i'll give you
another example a really good friend of
mine hussein jorday
who's over at google right now he used
to be at this company in toronto
and he had been working on i think uh
a pwa uh i can't remember which one
but uh adios money
got wind of it online and was looking
through it and
was like hey dude like i'd love to work
with you on this and
essentially they start to both work on
this project
a few months later a position opened up
over
google and he asked this gentleman my
boy
hussein to apply and you know the
application process took place
and he was able to join google so again
this is the idea of being public which
you work with which will at least
get you a look and then you know things
can go from there
well and i love that whole idea right
because i'm thinking through
you know how how i've ended up working
with some of the people that i work with
and
and sometimes it's because we we pulled
a resume out of the stack but a lot of
times it's
because we have prior positive
experiences with the people
and we look for their resume in the
stack and
that comes from anything that comes from
somebody that every time we talk to him
on twitter it makes us smile somebody
who is
always helpful in a community forum
somebody who is
part of the communities that we run in
who is just always helpful and
supportive and making people feel like
you know they can do it and just
somebody who you can see doing the work
like there are people who are early in
their careers
and i see them they're writing articles
they're they're sharing their works in
progress they've got those code pens
they're
seeing what somebody brilliant like like
cassie evans will do this amazing svg
animation
and they'll go and they'll fork it and
they'll alter it they'll you know like i
saw somebody did this yesterday
cassie was at smashing com and she did a
an animation of the smashing cat and
somebody went and put a guitar
on the cat right just like forked that
added a guitar and now the cat
rocks out and it's like what what a fun
way to
learn something show that you've done it
and if you're consistent with that right
and actually this is probably the thing
that is maybe the most important and
i'll let you talk about it because you
and i have talked about this a lot
but consistency continuing to show up
like
how big of a role has that played in in
your career
you know uh tremendous
i and uh i mean before i get into that i
want to actually
bring up another example uh because you
said something that
made me think of it i was listening to a
podcast
you know this gentleman bdoggy
[Music]
jamstack radio yeah and if anyone wants
to go
and listen to the very last or the most
recent one i think it's
episode 65 or 66 and
someone who is at a boot camp right now
uh prior to going to the boot camp i had
been
super curious uh and you know started to
poke around this actu this
gentleman came from music in fact uh and
he started to poke around you know
uh i think python maybe but he really
got into
development and uh
at the same time he was discovering you
know the jam stack
and i think he's been playing around
with redwood js
and so at the same time he was
attending the boot camp which is still
now i believe
he had been in the redwood js slack sort
of like
having these conversations with them and
you know
talking about things he was he was
discovering uh
with the framework and you know i'm
listening to this
thinking like the minute this gentleman
has done this program
he's got work waiting for him yeah
somewhere guaranteed and you know as i
was listening to him i was like this is
brilliant
because it was his early involvement his
early sort of
public commitment to uh to working with
this
you know this framework and trying to
figure out how it worked uh best
practices and whatnot
and just to hear him speak i was like
well you know this guy's got this guy's
got a job
you know certainly coming out uh so i
just want to mention that so if anyone
want to go back and listen to that
podcast but
getting back to your question which was
you remind me again
uh about consistency showing up oh yeah
absolutely
um i mean there are certain situations
where you almost have no choice but to
show up
and you know i think that i've put
myself that position in a sense that
you know as a freelancer you have to
poke around to see who's doing what
uh who's writing what uh keep that in
mind
uh also the idea of you know as an
organizer uh
you're also looking for people who have
interests in the field so that you're
forced again
to see uh who's writing what who's
speaking where
what was the talk about uh and this is
all information
that you take in so the only way you
find these things out is
is if you show up absolutely that's it
um
and you know again it's getting back to
the music pic right you know
it can be at times you're like oh man i
really want to stay home tonight
right you know i don't want to go see
this bed because i've been out three
days this week and
i would rather chill but
you make it out you'll be there for like
half hour 45 whatever and do what you
have to do and come back
i think it's a bit of the same you know
yeah in certain roles
in not all but certain roles uh being
out there
seeing who's talking about what knowing
who to reach out to in case you need a
particular question answered
a group of people may be able to answer
that question for you
you know joining some slacks and you
know you don't even have to
necessarily engage everyone but
watch the conversation that's taking
place uh
and a lot of times those are the nuggets
absolutely well and and just to kind of
you know to to expand on that even a
little bit more something that i think
is so
interesting is like you can you can see
when people consistently show up they
they start to become
part of a community instead of observers
in a community
and and one of the things that i've
noticed is that like
everything that i've done consistently
is a thing that i
now am able to do for work um
and and so i think a little i think of
it a little bit like
every time that i do work even if it
feels pointless even if it feels
like i'd like it's not what i wanted to
do you know like as you said i just want
to stay home and chill
if i if i show up and i do that work
that's a vote toward making that who i
become
and i want to cast as many votes as i
can toward the lifestyle that i want i
i love being able to do this show and
the only reason that quincy
reached out to me that i'm on the free
code cam channel right now
is because i showed up twice a week for
the last two years
on learn with jason right and and that
that was a vote for me being
a video internet person right
um but that's been true of all parts of
my career with the you know the the
development job now i have now nullify
and
and i i think that that just you know
that it seems
true for all of us you know and like we
talked about earlier you don't just do
development you you are all over the map
you've got you know you're running a
meetup you're running
you you're running like a clothing brand
you're running
uh you're you're freelancing like your
freelance consultancy like
all of that stuff is happening because
you're showing up and doing that work
and you know what the the the pins and
whatnot that was just
an opportunity to sort of you know
uh originally it was really it's a
mixture of two things you know
my background in music and yeah i used
to list a lot of rap whatever
although you know my range was like all
over the place
uh but you know i thought it would be a
very interesting way
of of you know breaking the ice when
meeting people
uh and you know sort of like you know
it's like a peace offering it's like hey
what's up i have these pins i hope you
like them whatever
and people are just like oh my god you
know and so that was like more fun than
anything but you know
in terms of you know my my current sort
of priorities
certainly uh you know freelance
development and in fact i told you i
thought you know when i discovered
you know i had a greater understanding
what the jam stack was
you know i think i told you i think i
told uh
phil i was like i think this is going to
be huge you know
especially for freelancers but
i also you know my parents are retired
teachers
and you know when you're when you're
young coming up you might look at your
parents you're like yo my parents are
awesome
but i'm going to get some cooler work
and i was just like teaching whatever
but you know with age i i start to
realize how important
uh being a teacher was uh being
a uh sort of like a figure that people
could potentially look up to
um and that just
took over and you know that's where the
the sort of the the fascination for
meetups
came from and and being able to create
a platform for people to come in and
shine
you know uh to start their careers
uh potentially with you know a lightning
talk
and then you know move that to a more
sort of substantial 30 45 minute talk
whatever
and then letting that take them where
where it may go and uh just because i've
seen it
uh and i think it's an opportunity also
to bring
my flair to that meetup ecosystem
and you know it might not be the meet up
that you used to
you know you roll in the music will be
different yeah well then the food might
be different
uh the emceeing might be a bit you know
have a bit more flavor
when and you just did like to to maybe
paint a picture of this
flavor a little bit you just did a whole
like themed 11d
event right uh yeah like so what was
november 11th so 11 11. you started it
at what time was it 11
11 11. and it was on 11d
but you know what again it's an
opportunity to spin
uh a very detailed development platform
into something that could be a bit more
interesting
uh just the theme alone and you know
it's funny you should mention that
and and you know i'll shout out the
speakers but
they helped in putting together
what was a super interesting in my
eyes event more people got
you know even more interested uh once
they understood what was going on and
they're like oh it's lightning talk
okay cool and we ended up getting some
of the
the best talks i've heard in quite a
while in terms
for sure as lightning talks because
everyone had a detailed
uh talk there was a fantastic talk by
uh dan fascia
on how he was living using 110 in a
medical profession
and i remember he had told me in the the
back channels that that's what he was
he was going to do and i was just like
oh i can't wait for this
i'm not belittling everyone else's talk
but
this is the idea that people can
discover
new things even though they believe
they're like oh i kind of know how to
liven your works and whatnot
but it was just like mind-blowing yeah
so
i like to enable that sort of element
that sort of
discovery element that needs to happen
at every step
and and that's you know and that's what
i think is is interesting and and one of
the reasons that
that i i love watching you work is that
i can
see you bringing the creativity from
your your previous roles
and trying to think about this stuff not
as well it's a meetup it's a tech meetup
it has to work like this
and instead thinking of it as a it's a
it's a gathering space we're going to
bring people together
and anytime people come together it can
be
stiff and very formal and and kind of
impersonal
or it can be wild you know like a house
party is just an
informal meetup right so how can we play
with the format how can we make
something that that doesn't just feel
like the thing we've always done but
something that feels unique something
that's remarkable and i think that you
have a unique talent for that
um and i i would i would wager and you
can confirm
that this has played a pretty
significant impact on on the connections
you've been able to make and what that's
been able to unlock for your career
certainly you know and um
i agree 200 with that you know and um
[Music]
i'll give you a quick story i remember
uh when
i was first coming in to the uh the
environment the industry
and someone had said you know you need
to attend meetups because
you know you're going to see and learn a
lot of stuff i'm like alright cool
whatever
and he had mentioned this one particular
meetup to attend they happen to be
friends of his
but i was like okay whatever and i
walked in
and i remember this like it was
yesterday i walked in
i looked around it was packed
and i was like okay this is really
interesting
and again you know you've had this hat
on i've worn it obviously
you know as people came from music a
full room to us
is like gold you know because we've had
those ones that were yeah
you know very you know sparsely attended
uh but that's just because we think like
so far ahead sometimes you know
but i remember you know sitting down and
listening to the meetup and
watching all the speakers and watching
the organizers sort of do the thing
and you know i paint a few of them i'm
like guys this is really good but
here are three things that i think could
be improved
and you know instead of just you know
peanut gallery
you know blah blah blah this this could
be improved and just walk away
i literally stepped to the organizers
i'm like hey gentlemen
you know this is great this is an
amazing audience
but i think this could improve and i
immediately start to share some of my
ideas and you know they told me there
after i mean
later on they're like you know when you
came up you know and start to criticize
us but
we're kind of like hey you know here's
some ideas there can like who's this guy
you know i ended up joining them and
i helped them sort of like develop uh
you know
better ideas uh and things that i
thought could be interesting because
again you have to look at a particular
topic and be like
okay this is cool but i think it would
sound better if we said this
and then we can go out and get this type
of
you know uh speaker uh
yeah i mean i i think there are so many
opportunities in tech right now to do
uh really interesting things despite the
fact that
we are pretty much online all the time
now um
it just might take that extra glass of
prosecco to really
let your mind wander and and expand on
this idea because i think
uh you know some of the best ideas are
hiding in
in sort of plain sight you know i think
there's a
levity thing i was just sitting right
there and because i remember
i was reading something about levity and
i'm like wait what's today's date
and i looked at my watch i'm like wait
november 11th is coming up
i'm like 11 is really buzzing and i'm
like
i know some 118 developers okay let me
reach out i reached out to them
and they're like dude this sounds pretty
interesting i'm like all right let's do
it
and you know we did a broad daylight and
it was awesome
yeah i think i mean it's it's so much
fun uh like i've said to
to watch you work it because you you do
bring that kind of fresh perspective you
you do interesting things that don't
follow the standard format
um and it's you know it's it's one of
the reasons that when i'm thinking of
how do we put together something fun how
do we put together something different
you're one of the first people that
comes to mind for that
um thank you and and i've i really love
to see that so
we're we're down coming down to the end
here so let's make this a little more
practical for the people watching right
now absolutely um what
what would you recommend both as as
learning practices
and as community practices like if
somebody was going to adopt
one or two habits today what should they
start doing if they're trying to land
that first gig
i would say um
okay so i believe there's a little bit
more clutter right now
and there are a lot of people trying to
do the exact same thing you're doing
which is land a job um
i mean this is a bit of a two-parter so
one
prime i'm gonna one sorry i would say
try not to stress it too much
because i think a lot of people are you
know they
consider themselves ready at some point
they're like okay where's the job
where's the job where's the job
you know how come i'm not getting any
offers try not to sweat that too much
but more importantly i think
as you you know shop around
stay active uh and you know to me that's
the biggest part
and staying active might mean uh
something to one person and something
else to some to
to another one but you know if
you do a lot of reading uh you know
blogs or you know you're looking at
you know uh i don't know uh tutorials
and whatnot
just keep going and and try to create
this environment where people can see
your work whether you're sharing this on
twitter
you have a github with or you have like
a code pen you know
shout outs to uh lintronix lin
mm-hmm lennon yeah linotonic like
her her one div thing is bananas that's
so good
like i don't know anything else about
her but i just know
she's you know she's a gangster with the
css yeah i'm saying
so share your stuff online you know
again whether it be
a codepen twitter or github
and um i would say that's like a bit of
a priority for me you know i mean
and and a lot of people like oh well you
know the resume this the resume that
yeah that's totally cool but you know
we're lucky enough that in this space
at the very least the work that's out
there that's public that's half your
resume
you know people are going to be like
okay they know what they're doing here
you know they'll go go ahead well i was
going to say for a lot of developers
like when when you send in your resume
your resume is basically a list of links
right and so you've got to build that
list
absolutely absolutely and you know
thereafter it could be a few different
things
obviously uh you know you'd be surprised
what you know being part of a community
might lead to
and that means you know if you get to
know some people and opportunities come
up
these people might ring you down to be
like hey uh
just sent you a little dm let me know
when you're ready i'd love to talk to
you
like for example you know and i'll i'll
shout you out in public for this that
time uh i heard from kraft
uh cms oh yeah and you know
it read like hey uh i'm from kraft
uh jason sent me here and i was like
okay
you know and i'm pretty sure i was like
you dude good luck
you know and uh thank you very much for
that but
these these are the things that i'm
talking about you know when
opportunities come around
someone might know you and say hey
i i think this is coming down the pipe
and uh i
i you know this this sort of like this
is your lane
you know let me know what you think you
know i'd love to set this up
um i mean in fact right before we got on
i was having this conversation with
someone about
potentially an opportunity early next
year so
i'm a big believer that you know being
public with your work
what you do and then you know being
involved with the community and you know
it won't go zero to 100 overnight but
you'll see
your network grow and and like you said
if you're that person that people just
love to see work and and and they smile
when you're around it's like they're
going to reach out to you as well
absolutely i it's that's played such a
big factor in my career as well you know
after
after i got i actually you know what
even when nobody knew who i was
the way i got my first job in tech is i
went to the local
coding meetup and i was in montana in
missoula montana
so this was 14 programmers none of us
wrote the same
language like i was a php dev there was
one other php dev most of them were java
we had you know it was like nobody was
doing the same stuff but we just get
together because we were the only
programmers in town
and through that we we became friends
and i got referred to a job
because they were a java dev and they
were looking for php and i was the php
dev so i got hooked up
because i showed up to this meetup right
and
those those connections they might feel
like nothing but they
they start to form a fabric and you know
that
that referral led to me giving my first
presentation at a meet-up led to me
giving my first conference talk which
led to more referrals
and all of that has been the snowball
that that got me to here
and you know you you made a really good
point about like not stressing at first
because
everybody's looking for their first job
and it takes a long time to get started
and it reminds me of a i wish i could
remember who said this but
there was a metaphor that i heard which
is starting a career is like rolling a
boulder
it is really really really hard to get
it to move that first inch
but as soon as it starts to move it
picks up momentum
and after a while you can't stop it
you're just moving and so you gotta
you gotta stick with it you gotta show
up and do that work every day to get
that first inch
um because it'll feel like nothing's
happening and then it'll all happen at
once
um totally so henry man thank you so so
much for hanging out with us this has
been an
absolute pleasure uh any final words for
folks before we wrap this up
oh man you know what um
just you know wake up and and and you
know smile
you know it's uh i think there are a
bunch of reasons especially now to
to sort of like be bummed out but i
think there's been
literally no better time to to sort of
like show your wares
um and and be part of a community
i mean and you'd mention the thing about
speaking uh opportunities and that's
something that i'm gonna work on in 2021
for for uh all uh devs out there because
um once upon a time you know you could
be in toronto and not
speak at the san francisco meetup but
you can now
yep you know so uh you literally have uh
for anyone looking
i think the opportunities have never
been better to to
to speak and as you said and i'll test
as well i think
uh from a lightning talk to a full talk
i think
speaking can do wonders for your career
as well absolutely
so henry where should people go if they
want to keep up with you what uh what
links would you recommend
honestly i'm a big believer of uh of
twitter uh
so ahri helvetica uh i'm usually pretty
quick on the on the uh
the uh requests you know any dms my dm's
are open so if you have questions i'm
always happy to do that
uh i've spoken to people from anything
from you know dev to like running
you know and uh yeah i'm happy to take
on uh
any questions you may have so twitter's
it twitter yeah
and and it's a great follow uh henry is
full of
excellent information on twitter and
that's gonna be it for us today so
uh thank you all so much for hanging out
with us today this is a series we're
going to be doing these every friday
so stay tuned keep your eyes glued to
the free code camp twitter
you can follow me at jlangstorff on
twitter and if you're into
live coding i also run a show called
learn with jason on tuesdays and
thursdays you can find
that at learnwithjason.dev and until
next time
that is i've said it before i'll say it
again thank you so much
uh yeah it's it's been an absolute
pleasure hanging out with you all and
we will see you next time